è vero che viene già tutti bene attenti
ragazzi prendete me sono video sono
affari cerchi siamo tornati su human
folk let visto che mi è piaciuto un
sacco
la scorsa settimana che l'ho fatto che
quel gioco dove il poliziotto mi toccano
chi la smetta ritocca smettila faranna
oggi a toccarmi sarà pietro tu riesci a
partecipare o ecco ti vogliamo tanto dal
cielo lo schermo nero o bianco si allora
dobbiamo se mi lasci la mano grazie
lo so che sei una persona molto
espansiva giorno di questa roba debba
andare giù guarda chi vuole che 2006
chiedono qualche 123 a
ha veramente funzionato un tuo fianco
come pietro non è molto stabile come
cosa però va bene ma scusami ma si può
trarre le finestre siamo magari
abbastanza a furia di mangiare al
mcdonald arkham h by pietro fammi vedere
come tutti giù quadrato by ami vedere
come sembrava tutto perfetto ha iniziato
da dio continua che sui forum la
bacchetta magica
finché che sei proprio un uomo ville
così guarda che sfrutta la fisica sembra
sembra rivedere un vecchio che cerca di
scopa brass dobbiamo saltare a eve
ragazza viene già tutti shop dove sei
pietro 26 qui a è come provare la
aggrapparmi a su cosa è odio mare fiere
più fenomeno di fenomeno geniale faccio
è che ne so ciao che grazie della mano
che vi segnalo un deficiente un
deficiente la faida che ci fai ci credo
in te bravissimo a braccio aiuto parla
di chi sa che lei si sia fatto ce la fa
ce la faccio torna dove stai andando più
a sei pazzo pietro mi sono schiacciato
da solo abbiamo messo c'è un altro
norcia
no è qua che devi andare a madonna che
letta e gatto sul marmo ho visto uno
spigolo andare via come questa roba qua
e non lo so credo la
ha funzionato e sta accadendo è non lo
so forse dobbiamo correre lo fa perfetto
bye bye bye bye bye bye
sono cose che ho fatto sono ancora in
affanno ma stavolta non siamo ormai ai
addietro pietro o mio dio nostro vedendo
adesso dietro c'era riuscito a te lo
giuro contraffatta salirà foto aiuta i
nostri costa grappa è difficilissimo
aspettare sentenze già molto noto
sorella ribasso hai fatto carlo mi
suicido no pietro madonnone idea ha dato
6 ricordi il suo movimento 6 rispetto
aspetta aspetta pietro pietro pietra e
sto facendo peso ma li maneggia al
minuto si spinga fino non è mai fatto
prima
ok blocca le pale pietro blocca le pale
damir cosa ottieni peep ha anche fatto e
sta facendo questo il blue me dobbiamo
connettere i cosi pure ma allora ma ci
avete la fantasia per le skifo e 2 e non
so metterle sì o no lo zio di oddio
oddio pensa di mettere allora il blu va
col blu che io sappia è blu bakwa siete
dei premi nobel che sta facendo questo
non lo so prendi questo gruppo a quel
blu ma pare che sta pattinando a villa
rosa peso ecco qua il rosso banco e
questo momento a tutti stracontento che
scemo per il tuo posto caro amico mio è
qua sotto
no non ci va no no non muoverti ti dico
dove devi stare tricoli dove l'estate
vistare devi stare di vistare depistare
sa cosa mi stava confondendo non ne
sentono più stavo ridendo la parlava sto
piangendo la cosa fa quello medio
blaiotta aspetto no no sono deficienti
scampini quoziente intellettivo di
biogas da rob ayoub alla lega salvati
che in casa batte ok perfetto all'atac
perfetto c'è un ascensore qua arrivo
arrivo schiaccia il pulsante ayami sono
schiacciati me prodotti defic a rischio
aia schiacciate non sono in mezzo ai
schiacciate il pulsante il ruolo proprio
punto porto
ok l'hack è male 2 ed efficienti center
o merda ero merda lo si sa merda se mi
sono incastrato una mano una porta
pietro mister incastrato la marina porta
apri dammi una mano a chi è entrato un
altro tizio ring la santa gesù cristo e
sfondato la tradizione è uguale a me
però sta fermo
o schiaccia quella maledetta schiacciato
il pulsante schiacciano e soprattutto in
casa ha chiesto tizio sosia schifoso
maledetto che ti permette di avere la
mia scheme fi giu lurido pezzente e non
sto care amiche mi dà fastidio come lo
sono io non devi toccarmi vi da fastidio
madonna direi basta mi sono rotto le
balle va bene lo abbiamo dato prova di
saper fare basta così e stata una sola
decine dimetri ragazzi spero che mi sia
piaciuto io con noi concludiamo qualche
sa veramente l'ultima ben sia stato
voglio morire morire per ragazzi un
certo felice che continua ciecamente di
legge residenti si siede e ci vediamo
prossimo avuto let's go tua madre della
ragazza
[Musica]